Ross it's great to see here at collector
mania today hi good to see you again how
are you very well thank you
now of course you've had a fantastic
season again on Game of Thrones I was
the white Walker now tell me a little
bit about filming your scenes for season
four Wow
season four was brilliant because I was
asked back as you know I died in season
three so I was very pleased that I got a
call to come back and they gave me a bit
of plastic surgery and revamped me and
gave me a new white Walker role as a
white Walker general carrying a baby
very important job to the night king and
I loved it it was fantastic I got back
on my horse again had a new set of armor
it was brilliant filming was fantastic
because I got to ride my horse through a
massive storm a blizzard of shredded
paper and smoke it was very harrowing
times but I made it with the baby in tow
so that was like my favorite bit filming
outside and you know I had to start work
at 1 a.m.
this time and then we started filming at
6 a.m. and then I wasn't finished till 7
p.m. so they were crazy days but I loved
it
I absolutely loved it what about the new
film that we filmed in just outside
Belfast yeah of course you filmed there
before haven't you
I have that's where my last white Walker
met his murky end before we move on to
Sam killing his first white Walker and
what did you think when you kind of
first got that script with the
appearance of the night's king because
it's made quite a stir among the fans
yeah I I thought um wow what's he going
to look like and then when I got into my
first fitting I got the the privilege of
looking at the first drawings and
sketchings of him and I thought wow look
at that he's got like a crown on his
head of horns how horrifying yeah it was
really eerie I thought how could it be
you know how could my character be made
even more scary and I think they've kind
of achieved that with a night king
and why do you think fans have been so
kind of excited about his first
appearance well I think because the
White Walkers are so shrouded in
complete mystery and you never really
know where we're when we're going to
show up how we're going to show up we're
going to want a baby we're going to be
stubbed we're going to be you know
what's going to happen to us where we
can appear in the episode if we're gonna
appear in an episode at all so I think
you know anything added to that you know
after I died last season I'm sure a lot
of people thought well maybe that's it
but we're never going to see them again
but you know lo and behold we're back
but then to have two White Walkers is
better than one whoa ha ha I love it and
of course changing a baby as well
I love stealing babies it's the only
place you're allowed to do it is on TV
because you cannot steal babies in real
life no that's really bad generally
frowned upon I think it's fair to say
very very frowned upon do not steal
babies people please send your white
Walker thing isn't it it's only a white
Walker thing we always give them back as
well but they come back as white walkers
we think you know I think they're
turning blue
so wait to see what happens next what
would you like to see happen now I would
like to see happening next that we see a
white Walker have a fight like a really
good fight with a dragon that's what I
would love a full-on screeching dragon
and a white Walker but I would also like
to see the baby white Walker grow into
maybe like a five year old white Walker
and then see him as a nine year old
Walker him and what's he like as a
teenager does he get stroppy and
difficult what was white Walker school
like how do you train a white Walker
that's what I want to see if you get
repulsion and kind of go clubbing and
stuff until the early hours of the
morning when I was teenager exactly it
does he does he does he do these things
weird where does he Club all night long
probably in Iceland or something you
know where it's like night time out of
the year
very good I like that definite I like
your idea bringing the oils of Ice and
Fire together as well with
Dragutin the white Walker oh yeah and
I'd hopefully get to meet Khaleesi
finally because she's my favorite now
what do you think the White Walkers are
up to well I I think the White Walkers
are expanding I think they're going to
take the wall and pass surpass do you do
you think that they want the throne
itself do you think such things that
human things are something that they
want I mean I'm not sure myself why do
they want to engage with others if
they're so isolated in themselves so
there must be something that they
actually want what would that be I
wonder I think George is the only one
who could really answer that is what is
it that they want because clearly things
like power is something you wouldn't
necessarily only be after like the other
characters the petty characters that
want just mere power
we don't need mere power we have all the
power maybe they want to take everyone
over like they done with the baby and
then the whole world will be White
Walkers so you think like the White
Walkers are maybe like the Borg they
just kind of take over the entire world
so everybody's blue and frozen only
world of all he's no fire anymore yet no
fire fire bad ice good invention of
course about filming with John Bradley
he plays Samwell Tarly
he had that very dramatic scene where
Sam it kills a white walk I mean what
was it like filming that it was like
being stabbed in the back by really good
friends I mean I've been working with
Sam for almost two years then and it was
very sad I'll tell you something very
funny though when I when I first arrived
on set for my rehearsals with Michelle
Maclaren Sam and Hannah Michelle said
okay see you're coming in you're coming
sort of over the mountain you come down
then Sam's can stab you in the back and
then you break into millions pieces and
you die oh okay
I'm sure you're joking me didn't nobody
tell you that your character is dying
and I mean
um no I don't think so and now Sherman
oh my god my worst nightmare should be
on set and tell an actor you've just
been written out in series I said oh
don't worry about that I'll probably
come back as another white Walker that
just changed my makeup she's like okay
if you're cool with that then let's go
let's continue so I was like yeah I'm
cool with it in season four we've also
had some rather incredibly exciting
moments haven't we we've had Joffrey's
death now it was your reaction to that
king toppling ha ha ha it was so good I
mean after the red wedding last year
which was incredibly moving inside at
the end of that season I thought okay
next season somebody mean has to die and
it has to be good and we have to really
enjoy it and that was really enjoyable
was so lovely to see him gasping for
breath in his eyes desperate reaching
for his mother looking around for help
no help to be found turning sour
disgusting it was brilliant I mean I
loved it I think I rewound it and
watched his second time to be honest
with you that I'm that horrible and
callous I watched it twice the thing
that really bugged me though was I just
wanted it to end there but when they
pointed it at poor Pete and I thought no
it's not him no don't end the episode
there we just want to have a good
feeling we thought no but he's not
guilty no he can't be
we love him now if you could think of
Joffrey's standout moments over the
course of those last four seasons which
ones particularly spring to mind for you
Wow
it's there's like every time he's on
screen he's amazing he's an incredible
actor that I will say I think his
character it's just hard to believe that
he's not that person and that is always
a really telling thing the poor guy he
must have a complex everybody must hate
him but um there are so many when he
first uh the one that I really liked
though was when he chickened out he kind
of coward it out in that in that battle
scene that was amazing
also when he had the mud pelted on him
when they had that parade through the
city I loved that they were like boo
I loved all that um it's like every time
he's on screen it's gripping and his
relationship with his mother I love that
I loved how painful it was for her when
he died I love because I loved watching
her in pain and her feel agony too it's
it's horrible it's a great show it makes
you feel really mean and dreadful about
you want people to be punished
definitely evokes visceral feelings
there's a dead god yeah that's what's
great about it keep watching it going
back to Joffrey's evil moments and I
thought was so depressing and horrible
was when he shot that prostitute with
the crossbows last season that made me
feel very sad and depressed and that
whole sequence of events that that was
so ugly to me I thought this world is so
hideous and evil I can't bear it how
like lame-o we see Ross Merlin back in
season five of Game of Thrones that's
what we want to know Wow
I want to know that too that's a really
good question
Dave dan you have the answers tell me
please if you came back what would you
love to see your white Walker doing in
future I would like to see some battle
because at my casting they said can you
use a sword have you done sword fighting
I was like it was the one thing I was
able to say yes because they said you
ride horse it was like no when I go
we'll teach here and I was like okay
then I was like no I can I can sword
fight and I want a sword fight so when I
come back I want to fight I want out I
want to fight Rose I just don't see
quickly about you know you got a movie
coming up how the horror movie and also
Doctor Who yes I've been on the new
Doctor Who the new Peter Capaldi um yeah
I can't tell you anything about it but
look out for me I'm going to be in a new
episode which is coming up in the new
season you'll be very excited it's a new
all-new creature
so it was very exciting to be on set
wonderful team to be with Doctor Who BBC
is wonderful to work with and yes I have
a new movie coming out called howl I'm
just started rehearsals on Friday
without I'm going to be playing a
she-wolf
it's a wolf based horror movie werewolf
based horror movie all set on a train
you can follow us on at howl movie on
Twitter I not wait for both of those
very finally what was it like working
with Peter Capaldi and what do you think
he's gonna bring he's bringing to the
part of the doctor Wow
Peter Capaldi was amazing an absolute
gentleman completely contrary to what he
would think he never swore at me once I
think he will be very cheeky funnily
enough for an older doctor he was very
cheeky and very fun very funny he'll
have the type of humor but he'll also
have like he'll bring it kind of a
wisdom in a sort of an edge to the
character which he has in all of his
work which is incredible cannot wait to
see all of those things and lots more of
you in Game of Thrones as well thanks so
much for oh thank you
you